there's so much knowledge out there so
much information so many ways to get
better and we make we make so many
mistakes where the were the product of
our mistakes and oftentimes the lesson
is sitting there right in front of our
face it's there to be learned but we
miss it or we don't pay attention to it
or we think we know better until it
punches us in the face and the most
important thing to learn is that we have
so much to learn we all do and we can
learn from school and from people and
from experience and we learn from life
but you have to process the information
you have to absorb it you have to accept
it you have to open your mind you've got
to free your mind so that you can learn
and make real progress and as far as
regrets and things I wish I would have
done differently of course hindsight
hindsight is 20/20 and looking back of
course who wouldn't want to take another
go at something and improve on the first
try by doing it again and then why not
do it again and again and again and why
not just do it over and over again until
you have it perfect but
fact is you don't get that chance you
get one shot one shot at this gig right
here life one life that's all you've
gotten and regret in and of itself it's
worthless it does nothing for you in
fact the only valuable thing in regret
is the lesson you learned the knowledge
that you gained but walking around
filled with regret it gets you nothing
so learn and move on
don't let regret beat you down don't be
a slave to regret no let it teach you
let it make you better let the fear of
regret fuel you to take action today now
to take action now to become a better
person not filled with regret but filled
with knowledge filled with knowledge and
strength and power and filled with life